what is that about human nature
um
is there some aspect of like the glory
you were able to achieve being more
important than anything else
there's some aspect of that that that's
that's greatness you know yeah I never
pursue Glory
so it's it just came you know it is it
came with it but that was never my goal
I never care for
Glory were you able to experience like
like I'm at the height of this thing
whatever whatever humanity is able to
achieve in various things holy [ __ ] I'm
flying I felt like
no one can touch me I can destroy people
yeah prolonged periods of time or just
momentarily
I I always knew you know from before I
got to a black belt like I I you know
it's I can be great because my program
you know I used to train with the best
in the world I used to you know it for
many years and I used to see my
progression with then everybody else so
I I knew I was getting somewhere I know
I could be the best
and that was that was always my goal
since very very young
and I always believed that I could be
and that over the years that kept
telling me over and over again because
I'm getting better and better faster
than everybody else
so it's I just need to carry on with
what I'm doing but I think you've said
that you wanted to
and maybe you thought you could be the
greatest of all time
like at the very beginning like when you
sucked yeah
yeah not not the greatest of all time
because
and I never really thought about that
but I thought I'm gonna be the best in
the world when I saw it when I saw okay
so what is that uh
what is that like that's self-belief is
there a component to that self-belief
being a prerequisite it's it's difficult
to say because that was a decision I
think
like why did I believe that could be I I
can't tell you that because I don't know
but you think you decided I decided to I
decided to be and I believed I could I
think there was like a day somewhere
when you were young where you're like
huh you're sitting at a couch eating
Cheetos I don't think it was them a day
like a moment because
for many years is I wasn't really
training much as a child you know I've
done a bit of I used to train and then
stopped on a bit of Judo never stay away
from it much but until you know it
like from 10 to 14 I barely trained Juju
so much I used to there was no greasy
school near where I used to live
and I was doing there was a judo school
I used to go twice a week
I'm going to introduce torment I lost in
five seconds left cried
the guy you pulled me in five seconds
anyway
so
when I was 14 I went to the south of
Brazil to see my uncle Helen
to spend some holidays I was there for
like four weeks I think
and I want to go there my cousin Hollis
were living with him Holly is like
bigger than me it was I think it's four
years four years older so I was 14 I was
already 18 17 18. purple belt competitor
and I think that was the first time in
my life that I felt what it mean
what it meant to be greasy
in terms of
having a school teaching training you
know living that you know judicious
lifestyle what a greasy meant to be and
I've just I've loved it was out of shape
my uncle was like you know incentivizing
me to lose weight to train but you're
not training why you know it's like
you've got a shape you need to diet so I
used to run every day I was eating super
well I started you know I started that
when I start changing so when I go back
to Rio was super motivated to follow up
carry on and he you know he invited me
to go back there to live with him but I
couldn't it was too soon in to change
schools and everything my mom said no
but maybe next year if you want to go
you can
so I kept that in my mind next year
hey I moved to the South to live with
him I was 15.
and it was him my uncle Helen and my
uncle crawling they both used to live
very close to each other they used to
have their own schools close to each
other so I was with both and I stood
there for almost a year I mean I was the
youngest in the academy there was some
you know blue purple Bells normal guy
but they're very competing training
ahead of me and I just joined the group
of training I didn't compete while I was
there because there was no composition
that then and I wasn't really ready but
it's not about company it's not about
the training and I start training every
day start improving and year after that
when I came back to Rio I was already on
a mission I was like I love this I'm
just carrying on training every day
because my uncle Carlos Carlos Gracie Jr
Grace about
and the one I got there I was training a
little bit that before but I just 14 15
but when I got there
there was a you know there was one of
that was one of the most competitors one
of the biggest Jiu-Jitsu schools at the
time there was so many high-level World
champers competitors in every single
belt yes and I've kind of joined in with
that
and I've carried I don't remember when
but I remember you know looking and
saying I'm gonna be the best in the
world but I used to be I was at the
bottom of the stairs you know no one
really believed me I didn't shower you
know to disguise but you know I told a
few people I'm like I'm gonna be the
best
and that's I think up
I was just losing but I've never ever
doubt I've never divert from that
Mission outside did anyone believe you
when you said you could be great nobody
did it matter it didn't matter I don't
care I don't need even people that I
like love you everybody my mom my dad
not me no one thought no one in my
family thought I was gonna be here today
nobody
because I just started late you know
I've I've never had any start that
people or that kid's gonna be really
good you know I'm always a chubby kid
that didn't barely train I mean people
used to look at me he just another
greasy this
you know one more
what do you learn from that do you think
most people
lose that self-belief they quit when
everyone around them doesn't believe
yeah I think
if if it doesn't need approval yes
but I see you shouldn't have approval
and I'd never need approval from anyone
I don't care if you we believe you're
not if you
not my problem it's tough it's tough I
don't need approval but
you're surrounded by people older wiser
better than you and they're kind of
directly or indirectly saying you stop
being silly kid no one ever told me that
because I I it's not that was not
something that I used to say all the
time I'd maybe say it just very very few
times
I just go you know maybe that's the
secret of course I mean if you start
shouting then you've just been silly
then it's not what you really want then
you're saying that for another reasons
if you say it over and over again
because you shouldn't I mean that's why
well to push back one of the reasons you
might want to say it is to find the
right people that believe in you yeah
but not if you say over and over again
then it's just then you're just bragging
sure because
one thing is to say it but the other one
is to do it
so it's you know you say that once or
very few times but now you have to do it
saying it's not helping you getting
there was there sacrifices you had to
make everything
everything that was my priority in life
everything was secondary like social
life
career paths yeah everything
and is it from 14 15 16 as you get
better and better and better and better
it was just becoming sharper the focus
on this thing yeah it's just over and
over again over and over again it's you
know it's just training training
training and I mean how many times I
lost I I have no clue so on the mat you
were getting beat up I'm getting smashed
by everybody
people my age I was chubby I was
physically weak I mean I'm tall but
physically I'm not physically strong I'm
normally strong for my size but
physically
if you want to measure strength I'm weak
because you know we can measure strength
living with lifting weight I'm weak I
don't lift I lift weight same as people
much lighter than me everybody my my
weight leaves have heavy weights and
then people that train with you often
talk about how they think you're super
strong yeah because I generate a lot of
strength I can create I I put myself in
the right angles
so then I can be strong I'm not strong
and the only person who I listen to
saying that is uh computer one guy that
I fought
him a few times
and he's the only one that I heard
saying about me there's like no Roger's
not strong
he's not he's Technical and he's he can
create strength but he's not strong he
meant that as a compliment
yeah I think so no I think he was honest
because he I think he's the only one who
could see that yes so I think that's a
compliment he's technically so you had
an incredible matches with him yeah
is there a
Insight you have about how you went from
a person
who was not very good
but had a a dream
a confident dream
a vision
to somebody that was actually good was
there something to the practice sessions
were you getting reps on the specific
techniques I'd never done anything
special because I mean you know I'm in a
gym training equally with everybody else
so I've never did anything on the side
different than anybody else so you know
I was in the school training the exactly
same way as everybody else well in terms
of schedule yes but what was can you
reverse engineer what was going through
your mind because there's so many
different ways to actually mentally
approach these same exact training
sessions I'm gonna try to be
okay so in some part is competitive yeah
like at the core of it
is I want to be better than these
particular people you're gonna keep
beating me I'm gonna keep coming back at
you and to do that I have to solve
problems I have to figure out how to do
stuff you catch me once
I'm Gonna Keep On Coming trying to
unlock
get get caught on that at which point
did you develop a game that was
basically the white the famous white bug
game of the very Basics the very
fundamentals of Jiu Jitsu like
saying I'm going to beat you
there was never there was never a
conscious decision to to try to you know
to have a basic judicial first
I think there's a big misconception
there okay
it's not you're right it's not basic
it's not old school I think people they
just don't see that it's extremely
complex
in a way that is is people they cannot
copy I teach people you know I can teach
you
the cross color choke but the one thing
that people didn't realize
is not the move is you need to practice
the move until you learn
is the practice over and over again like
it took me years
when I say ears I'm like years after I
was a black belt I was able to choke
people out with a cross color chalk in
the mouth effectively years after I got
my black belt so that's something that
you learned first day first week
so I can't teach you it makes no
difference
you you know the theory but until you've
applied it and you help you of course
the more details you learn you know the
the more tools you have to practice but
it's still very complex because it's not
about the move itself it's about how can
you control the movement of the other
person
he's resisting you're blocking you
cannot predict what he would do and he's
doing a whole bunch of moves to to block
you every single move you do a step of
the way because it's a is is a
progression of move from beginning to
end till I apply the choke it's a
progression of moving there's not one
way to get that there's many ways
because how many ways can you blocked
you can put your arm in every single
angle we have both arms you can Bridge
so it's dealing with all that that is
the yeah that is the complex complexity
of the position but that goes for
everything like every single move
my strong moves I would say it took me
years developing them years so it's then
you're gonna tell me that's basic so go
try and do it what the other person is
defending that's the thing because most
of the things that I do
have been doing them for years and I
they know that I'm gonna do and I can
still
get it most the times that's the hardest
is when they know what's coming and you
can still do it and he said that the way
you're able to do that you just have to
do it right yeah